got to tell you i'm a little bit nervous
here to make sure that i take this test
and i look like a very stable genius
like our president and not like my brain
is made of pudding like joe biden
and speaking of finding that
centeredness speaking of this chaotic
nerve-wracking world
i have got to thank our wonderful
friends who are sponsoring this video
over at hallow hallow is an audio guided
catholic meditation
and prayer app it's sort of like head
space or calm but for prayer not just
about mindfulness and meditation
it's sort of similar to that but then it
goes further to talk to god
it is the number one catholic app in the
united states
free to download there is tons of
permanently free content
you can also upgrade to unlock all 500
plus
sessions with a subscription you know me
i'm kind of an old school rosary guy so
i was skeptical of the technology
it really adds so much to your prayer
life to a prayer regimen it's just a
wonderful app
for a 14 day free trial you can go to
hello.com michael
that is hello.com michael or just click
on the link in the bio
after i totally ace this test now that i
am
totally centered not just by by that but
by
being here with you i will find out if i
am a very stable genius
or less than a very stable genius let's
take the test all right montreal
cognitive assessment solve the following
puzzle
1 goes to a 2 goes to
b b goes to 3.
3 goes to c
c goes to 4 4
goes to d d
goes to 5 5
goes to e hope i got it right
draw a copy of the cube
i might run out of space here but that's
all right
this is bringing me back to the third
grade
okay
okay hope i did that correctly oh
there's another question
i hope i don't get points off for not
seeing that question draw a clock
at 10 minutes past 11. okay
go clock 12
three six nine
so ten minutes past eleven o'clock
so the short hand is going to 11
the long hand going to 10.
there we are name the animals
this is a lion
[Music]
next one is a rhinoceros
oh is this this is the one i don't know
if you if you caught it on cnn
don lemon didn't know what a rhinoceros
was making fun of how
stupid and easy this test is what were
the animal shapes
uh well it's a lion a hippo
and a camel isn't that a rhino in the
middle or i know
you don't even know
man i bet even joe biden would have
gotten that one also i'm looking at it
backwards
like is a rhino backwards a hippo i
don't think so
uh but he he gave us the the third one
but it's pretty clearly a camel
there it is i remember that from all the
cigarette commercials as a kid
number five is to repeat the following
series of words
face velvet church
daisy red face velvet church daisy red
repeat the following numbers in order
two
one eight five
four two one eight five four
killed it totally killed it uh repeat
the following numbers in reverse order
seven four two
two four seven that's it three numbers
that's all
wow it's easy easier to go backwards
than forwards hold up
the a sheet of paper every time you hear
the letter
a okay got my a right here f
b a c
m n a
a j k
l b a
f a k
d e
i get all the a's i think i got all the
a's
serial seven subtraction starting at 100
verbally give the first five serial
subtractions of seven
starting from 100 okay 100 to 93
86 79
72 65.
all five cool repeat the following
sentences
i only know that john is the only one to
help today
i only know that jon is the only one to
help today
the cat always hide under the couch when
dogs were in the room
the cats always hide under the couch
when dogs were in the room
list the similarities between the words
listed example banana
orange equals fruit so i guess just one
similarity
a train bicycle modes of transportation
i would assume watch ruler
methods of measurement ways to measure
things
is that it do i can now be the
republican
nominee for president because i'm a very
stable genius
i cannot be the democratic nominee for
president because
my brain is working too well works for
[Music]
me